There have been many cases where he's basically been treated as if he doesn't
exist. They use the wrong photo for him.
He tweeted out that every other campaign gets to have, um,
people who represent them on your shows. But with him,
it has to be him personally.
So when people on the left are starting to realize, Oh,
this isn't about Republican versus Democrat. This is about us versus them.
And you could just as easily be a Democrat and be them, eyes are opening.
And that is a very, very healthy phenomenon.
I always say that the corporate press is the enemy of the people.
And I think that's the moderate position.
This is the Rubin report. And according to a Russian bot farm, I'm Dave Rubin,
quick reminder guys, to subscribe to our YouTube channel,
which gives you a 5% chance of actually seeing our videos in the feed.
Pretty good. Joining me today is the author of the new right? The host of the,
your welcome podcast and the man that I've dubbed the Willy Wonka
politics. Michael malice. Welcome back to the Rubin report. Thanks so much.
Well, sir, where to start? Um,
I think your outfit. Yeah,
it reminds me of somebody, a former guests.
I didn't see you until two minutes ago.
You walked in here wearing this gorgeous little thing. Yeah.
Yeah. I've been known for this look four years, is that right?
All of a sudden I get phone calls.
Who's this woman Tulsi who has been dressing like you she's so nuts.
She even put a streak in her hair to pass as me even more. And I looked this up,
she says, she's from this state called Hawaii life. I never heard this.
There's a bunch of volcanoes in the middle of the Atlantic.
And we're supposed to believe that this is a state. They live in volcanoes,
rain of liquid metal that they check the weather. And this is people.
This is how they gerrymander the electoral college.
And now they're trying to say, Graham's a state.
When I asked my friend where's Graham, find to me on the map,
he points this little Island by the booth.
You saying glam, glam, Graham, have you ever found, they're making up words.
This is how the fake news media gets over it. Anyway,
getting back to her campaign. I think she's great. Yes.
I've been following her very closely and I think it's reprehensible.
What's being done to people like Telsey Gabbert,
the Congressman from so-called Hawaii and all the other democratic outliers. Uh,
this is a wonderful, um,
change in our politics where so many people are realizing the nature of the
enemy.
All right. So we're going to talk about all of that stuff,
but because a huge portion of our people just listen to audio.
I do feel that I have to describe what you're wearing hunky.
You are in a white leisure suit. It's a suit.
This is a business to have your leisure suit. It seems like a leisure.
So you look like leisure suit Larry,
or you look like Larry from a three's company or something like that.
Or we can do this to John Johnson or John Travolta. Yeah.
Like suit, but you are, no, this is very much the Tulsi Gabard whites.
This is the Michael malice look that tells the appropriate.
Yes, yes, yes, no. Okay. So you hit, you hit a whole bunch of stuff there.
The reason that I wanted to have you back, because as you know,
I find you to be one of the most interesting political thinkers out there.
I do think there you go. I'm paying you a compliment right? In front. You,
you consistently strike me as someone that is always like really on what I would
say is the forward fringe of what's happening culturally and politically and the
whole shebang. So let's, let's start where you just started there.
That there suddenly seems to be a couple outliers with the Dems and,
uh,
the DNC or the powers that be are the gatekeepers or the New York times or CNN
or whatever else you want to call that. Not too happy.
Yeah. For a long time, conservatives often get things wrong. Um,
and I criticized them very heavily on my Twitter. And when I speak to them,
I do so with great love and affection. Um,
they have always argued that the media is a wing
of the DNC.
And what we're seeing recently now is it's more accurate to say that the DNC is
a wing of the media because, uh,
you'll see things like anyone who deviates,
as you mentioned earlier from basically the media's party line is crushed.
Let's, let's give an example. I'm a democratic Congressman, right?
Let's suppose from Hawaii or some other, or from a real exists.
And for three years,
my constituents have heard CNN and MSNBC talk about Russia, collusion, Russia,
collusion, Trump's Hitler. Trump's this Trump's that?
How am I as a politician supposed to go back to my constituents and
say with a straight face, I think Trump's the worst president ever.
I think he's a racist concentration camps. Uh, you know,
despicable he's ruined the presidency,
but I don't think this is grounds for removing him from office.
I don't have that space. So it's pretty clear.
Who's the one who was leading the charge and who was following it.
And for a long time, again,
conservative thought this was Republican versus Democrat.
And now we're seeing that it's establishment versus outsider because we're
seeing it, how they treated Tulsi. We're seeing it,
how they treated Bernie and Andrew Yang.
That's the special one because Andrew Yang is hardly some wide-eyed radical,
right? He's a. He's in many ways, akin to Mitt Romney. Uh, you know,
in certain ways he wears the math lapel pin. He wants people to succeed.
He's a business guy and mostly a centrist probably,
or not probably certainly way too big government for you. Right? Sure.
But at least you think he's a sort of functional human being and doesn't come
out of the machine.
Right. And he is,
there've been many cases where he's basically been treated as if he doesn't
exist. They use the wrong photo for him.
He tweeted out that every other campaign gets to have, um,
people who represent them on your shows. But with him,
it has to be him personally.
So when people on the left are starting to realize, Oh,
this isn't about Republican versus Democrat. This is about us versus them.
And you could just as easily be a Democrat and be them, eyes are opening.
And that is a very, very healthy phenomenon.
I always say that the corporate press is the enemy of the people.
And I think that's the moderate position.
What is the corporate press really? Like?
What is the psychological makeup of the corporate press that causes this whole
thing?
Sure. So basically what you have are the universities and that's where the evil
starts.
And we've been trained since kindergarten in our government schools to regard
the media as authoritative and as you know,
hardworking people fighting for the little guy and trying to present the truth.
Yet we see many, many examples of the little guy.
Nicholas Sandman is a very obvious example. Uh,
those cadets who were playing the circle game, uh, the guy,
here's an easy example. The guy who Photoshop CNN into that, uh,
gift with Trump, wrestling them, CNN said, we reserve the right to Sue you.
To hunt him down and destroy him for creating a meme.
Not looking out for the little guy that's looking out for number one.
Do you, I I've asked a bunch of guests to this year,
but do you think there's a moment where something changed because it wasn't
always this horrible it's being exposed now more because,
because we can all immediately tweet out the truth. The second, you know, they,
they pump out the lie,
but do you think there was some other seminal moments somewhere along.
It was always this horrible, and this is what conserves don't appreciate.
We all learn in high school about William Randolph Hearst,
the Spanish American war. Remember the Maine and yellow journalism.
And then they just kind of the record scratch. And now we're into today. Uh,
I have a big thread on Twitter. Walter Duranti is a prime example.
He was in New York times, man, covering the Soviet union.
And while Stalin intentionally committed a genocide via starvation of Ukraine,
the Holodomor, he was putting out dispatches all the time saying,
there's no problem. If there is a problem,
it is malevolent propaganda. He said the Russian people, it's a little tough,
but they're tightening their belts.
Tighten their belts is a very interesting idiom in this context. And what they,
what Stalin did to these people is, uh, if you were a Kulak,
which meant land owner, but pretty soon, man, anyone,
if you had any food in your home, that was for the people,
they ran sector house and took it. And if you weren't starving,
that's how they knew you were hiding food and that's who they targeted.
So they would beat people, mercilessly. They would tear their house upside down,
kick them out in the streets, you know, so to start,
and there was another reporter who were willing to this area was forbidden
by the Soviet government. There was a reporter who jumped off the train, uh,
went to a few villages, reported back what was happening, these horrors.
And Duranti was like, Oh, you know, he's just an anti-Soviet agitator.
So this has been going on for a very long time.
They've always been hardcore. I call them jihadis without the testosterone.
They have been
very demented idea ideology that will do everything in its power to maintain its
hold on power.
And only now that they've been fact check in real time and called out on their
tactics in real time, are people realizing, Oh,
I'm just gonna say one more point. It's not. I had this tweet yesterday said,
it's not about the corruption. It's about the depravity. If it was just, Hey,
I'm hiring my brother and he's getting paid too much money soon asked no one
would care. This is, we know they do that. That's fine. [inaudible]
this is about Amy Roebuck and Jeffrey Epstein.
When you have a network that knows that someone is engaged in this sexual
trade of children and their concern is not getting an interview with Meghan
Markle. And when this is exposed, instead of coming clean, it's,
let's target the person who revealed this footage and get them fired at the
network, which they went to.
It's a lot, it's a lot, it's a lot.
But what do you think about the sort of psychological condition of these people?
Like when I watch all of these clips of CNN anchors
saying the reverse of the truth or Cuomo tweeting out that, you know,
look at the way the right attacks Gretta thunbergii when he went after Nixon,
men are just, Oh, you know,
a kid is all of this nonsense that they never stop.
They seem completely psychologically unable to stop.
And that strikes me as very weird. You know, I sit with a lot of people.
If you were to say something to me that was patently true.
That was against what I believe I would struggle with it. I would,
we would work it through. I would ask you some questions, but I know myself.
I would probably change my mind if you made a compelling case.
We now we're at a point where there's a lot of compelling evidence that these
people lie endlessly and nothing ever stops them.
I, I don't even know that I would use the word lie.
And here's why I talk about this heavily in the book I regard, uh,
what I call the evangelical left these types when you're, uh,
an adherence to a fundamentalist, creed facts do not change your opinion.
In fact, contradictory facts make it double down, right?
So if you are talking to someone who is a hardcore creationist and you show them
fossils, they're not going to wonder if creations was wrong.
They will regard this as evidence that their willpower and faith is correct.
And this is just the test and it's the exact same psychology, the contemporary,
and I don't regard all leftists in this vein.
I regard this specifically as these Jihadi types,
they have this vision that they are the ones who are going to save
America and the world.
And it's the degeneration of what happened a hundred years ago called the social
gospel, which was the premise that instead of an individual being saved,
which is a basic premise of Christianity, it's the nation that has to be saved.
However,
when you have this worldview that a nation's soul can be saved or the earth
soul can be saved.
That means there is no space that is outside your purview.
That means whatever someone watches, whatever someone does at home,
anything aspect of your life is subject to their domination and control.
So it is an absolute totalitarian worldview and they admit it.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.